yeah welcome to this video after a while
um after some break let's say I'm going
to play the Daisy danyoung war zone
final unknown on chest cube again I
haven't done that for a while so let's
enter I was close to forgetting that
just to enter the tournament alright so
let's see what happens this is sad
two-minute chess and the game doesn't
seem to start I know it's signing and
always need to double up here yeah some
semi sloth let's see let's just playing
there should be seven so we got a
regular Queens gambit declined position
with an early c6 I like to play Quincy
to and rook the one against this kind of
setup making it difficult for like to
play see 5 15 now ok now can take or can
place the fiber just go see 5 shut down
give me some nice space advantage yeah
is he all managed Fisher basics but it's
still no this is a pawn just grab the
phone here hmm it's got to no
compensation whatsoever
nitey 5c form so my next idea yeah I'm
just taken to me it's not too great I
think this looks better can play you for
and kick the night out again still
planning it for yeah okay don't mind to
retreat mm-hmm yeah just just another
pawn right based on the the Queen
position okay let's scrap here and how
to continue now like to regroup the
snide play F 3 yards i may be here there
should be three coming or preparing
exactly this move this looks like good
control it takes just dropped eggs and
everything's nicely covered with them
how much two extra pawns can also just
take before i think
yeah oh this is just taking quite long
it is this the only problem with this
game you need to win quickly here yeah
okay one on time and some people have
already won two games so let's open for
quicker win of course no draw yeah this
is a bit risky with this value c5 but um
don't to get some aggressive play going
is playing a strange stuff awesome so
yeah yeah see but the problem is that at
the end I'm I've got all active pieces
what this 94 since is just great for
black what does he sacrifice the Queen
now probably will yeah keep back the
night now attacking the bishop the swish
it needs to stay passive so let's just
play plaque to play take here an island
grill at five so that i can now quickly
attack f2
someone should I play d4 now it's not
good address now just quite better as
this I think and now we're taking the
wiki three Pawn now takes Queen at four
and one I need to use some better
coordination here yeah this blunders
more material can take on bitter at all
piece design ii too and yeah I all
pieces really um okay I can take its
just oh just one check on c4 yeah
without any kind of justification white
plays on and harms both players chances
to get anything in the tournament yeah
it's absolutely pointless just wasting
points and now we resigns so just as
lost as it was one minute ago but yeah
whatever so let's see what happens um
someone's got three games but I'm not
quite sure I get some points with two
games but somehow it happened
okay skyress resigned someone is on
three three out of three yeah I haven't
played on chess cube for some time and I
need to readjust to a bit to the candle
flow here it's all a bit different on
those various platforms in terms of how
my how quick the pieces move and so on I
hope I'll be able to play em play
decently this looks weird allowing this
spin maybe it's not terrible but yeah
okay I can just take it right I'll
probably cover g5 yeah let's open up the
position this must be good gether if you
had another pawn here yeah usually the
exchange row is not the kind of opening
way when clicked leave it here really
quickly got a better position down some
three pawns up
yeah this guy is just playing on like
nothing has happened yeah I gave back
some points are not entirely necessary
it still is so just an just winning yeah
okay for us coming and I'm promoting the
f1
um this isn't Stan melter and mate next
move okay so at least I'm winning a
couple of games it's not too too quick
young but against letting the time run
down of course yeah this is why I don't
play those tournaments so often anymore
you just um meet people simply want to
harm others they're not interested in
their own their own tournament really
they just think okay I'm let the clock
run down the other guy will suffer and I
don't count all right next game all
right this is so comfortable line for
white man up done supplier can vary your
setups here will show me what you're
good ok it's to exchange now after the
night is on d 7 this is some big
difference if you would have an idea
he's so rebooting the knight to c6
prolly I should play this to react to
that hmm interesting question how how to
continue I don't have have so much time
try to use the development advantage
it's not clear this is good now this
some looks fine for white and what same
take on d5 I can take with the rook
goodnight f6 check coming down now
what's it doing now it takes Bishop
takes I win in exchange okay says
something better don't think so okay
let's just double down on the default
John ya rabi g 7 wouldn't be so good but
let's let's go here threaten b3 taking
away squares from the night of how to
see Kevin now the snide with three was
the rather obvious threat at fault just
in alright so second place someone is
some playing rather quickly as well he's
got three points more I don't know why I
got some yeah I got one instant resigner
right what
yeah the bogo yeah black exchanges the
dark squared bishop and now put salt
ponds on dark square so it's a rather
healthy structure threatening yeah
thrive fat this one but he didn't react
winning a piece now can nice would be
resigns but probably not yeah it's
always nice to have an extra piece will
try to use it for attacking purposes on
the King side yeah now the pawn on d5
the bishop is a really stupid looking
piece so let's just reroute
yeah it's a bit bit annoying this rock
on the seventh I'm not sure what does is
doing but probably I shouldn't have
weakened the position so much yeah how
do I get rid of this rock it's not not
so easy let's protect this yeah I'm not
sure I don't take a shot should really
take on on c4 not sure it's a bit bit
tricky now anyway with them the time
disadvantaged position is probably still
so good but I don't have I don't have
any time left yeah twin 2h7 I know it's
really a nuisance yeah no it'sit's fine
again but not sure up the time
yeah okay he was slow yeah really bit
shaky play them he got some activity on
the iphone with the piece down okay
let's try to get some simple setup here
yeah but who cares shouldn't be too bad
having the G file open yeah we should be
form it wasn't the most sophisticated
idea ever but you should try in two
minute games sometimes you hear simply
will win who will win easy games okay so
he formed yeah come on let's play you
for its not sure it might be weakening
night add some where each five or so no
okay what this is ok it's just them
close the position
one but the be porn isn't too bad really
I hope it that pays off to have to sleep
on so should i should i take now and
I'll take on e4 mmm I still slow why not
why not retake okay one King be to rook
to e1 quindi one probably Bishop takes
e5 at the end or even now that's really
amazing sometimes people play tons of
bad moves in a row and then they see
this kind of stuff okay I can take and
then Queen Quincy five yeah what is this
position you're threatening clinic to
this is really the problem
damn it what a game I mean just utterly
winning and then he found all this stuff
will you should take c5 know yeah but
gonna do all right should some get some
usually more successful if you just play
play simple chess and don't expose your
king and stuff like that because they
won't simply Blunden on make strategical
mistakes ok some bogu indian again just
some good strategical opening not sure
what this is doing it cannot really play
a form g take so I'm 94 just win support
and rook takes yeah i mean is just two
digit lead to terrible I've f55 square
now enter why doesn't have any
particular compensation now I have the
e-file and it's very weak on the dark
squares goodnight c5 g3 coming as one
possible IDM
alright so let's give this check and
play 93 don't really see how it defense
after that King really yeah maybe looks
terrible but maybe it's um it's the only
move hmm yeah Queenie one checkmate this
would be nice nice to somehow get
working but don't see how don't see how
long yeah it's just very nice and
comfortable but not not winning
immediately
yeah he went on I will do some time also
this is why I'm not exactly looking for
the most exact moves at the moment I
just want to win this on time get this
game in the books yeah I'm 40 points on
behind the first place due to the silly
loss get some Queens gambit exchange
some position type oh yeah and yet again
I'm trying wrong castle okay this is
some stir different yeah this Queen now
has problem Queen a three rugby three
and it's trapped you still trying to
play some good moves for change oops I
wanted to play a five
yes still it looks like a very good
Kings Indian or Dutch structure wow
really this looks weird really weird so
let's um let's see what I can I allows
me to play it for NASA surprising yeah
looks look so just just good for black
can allege that just push the points now
these two points on should be should be
dangerous okay once play rookie seven
yeah hmm i see a guys night e six okay
let's just push this cannot believe him
that he's got enough enough going
rookie 7i display 96 and don't see the
big point threatening work g8 no and f 1
and E 2 I just need to get rid of this
rock and it's over the two points just
win now just don't get me to dance um so
silly fashion it it can happen sometimes
I don't just don't just don't see it
ropes III still I've got T to come on
let's just keep it simple mom alright so
I'm in the hunt but still behind and so
for quick win for a change
maybe he allows Bishop e3 so that it
cannot cancel short and on canceling
longer might have some ideas so let's
see maybe I can get something going to
to a 6cm looks looks nice how do I get
them rook rook before to a4 a5 b5 form
very crude maybe maybe too crude don't
know but this is the threat now how do
you defend a 7 now
mmm yeah I mean it's to move the Queen
probably yeah this is check man okay so
second place some some guy has got 11
out of 11 I didn't play him yet I think
yeah I'm trying form a simple setup here
that allows me to play some some moves
quickly the idea is to get rid of the
bishop which one which are managed and
then of course in addition you want want
to have from the slight square control
now I try to get the king in the center
which is usually a good place for it so
all right so I'm exchange all heavy
pieces okay why not why not use both
they're both nights try to get something
going here on the queenside yeah a
foursome possible weakness I'll take
this with the night how to continue down
maybe I need to
switch the Queen over somewhere here on
the kingside no idea why you would open
it up himself it's got the Queen tied to
the a41 all the time and now I'm able to
enter here look strange to me at least
why would you do that ok so now I can
exchange the bishop if I'm able to
exchange Queens that I should be a
should be in good shape may be here all
right I need to be able to move the
night on c4 or should I play night CA to
e7 now maybe the c8 e75 this could be a
good idea hmm this looks all very very
shaky for what i'll probably go no time
anyway now I wouldn't burn the porn mp4
ever ok so second place
this myth [ __ ] maybe a good opening to
to get a point yeah page five very weird
yeah this is simply not working at all
but I mean what the heck is he doing I
you can just just take everything here
what now Queen takes everything went see
are to be five also nice made okay three
points but then some people are really
close
okay let's let's keep it relatively
solid I was briefly thinking about some
f5 stuff which is sometimes play with
them he's a bit too good for this you
came let's see if he grabs the I grab
see even this pawn yeah this is some
really um tough gambit line where wide
snatches two pawns but gives black a
pretty big initiative for the two pawns
dumb I don't think I'm it is
particularly good read but then it's not
so easy and numb this rapid time
controls like two minutes okay exam is
simply grabbing everything right okay
I'll take the Queen what do we had game
okay you know this guy it's got a pretty
pretty big amount of points so on and
names oh and r transpose to the samish
variation always fun to play mickael
ouch you should be filings some usually
I'm bit risky to allow that okay
I haven't yet yep castled and his son
King position isn't done yet doesn't
this inspire much confidence now this is
so this is a pin and the last you want
to help hard time to break what yeah but
this is this is too easy now Quincy form
yeah so i'm i'm on first place to this
for the movement ok again up this line
and it's not too bad for what but he
needs to really know what what is doing
for started again how to play this
something like this but not exactly this
i think it all right let's just play
normal moves it took him quite some time
here to exchange pieces and i'm i still
have some nice center ok how to continue
not f60 probably will just take don't
want dad ok son shop this and the column
it's probably useful
mmm I cannot exchange quiz better not
but now I've got 94 and in the mix
should I place a move like before here
not probably not just attacked III okay
okay let's try let's try something here
getting a night to be three doesn't look
too bad what about f4 since this may be
actually could have done this earlier
Adam looks and looks dangerous okay he
tends to take her there now this is bad
maybe something like this now take care
if it takes a 7 I can't take F to this
these points are dangerous this this is
a this is some good for Mia come on two
pawns must win the game now yeah
yeah that's psycho for this delayed
Smith Maura okay doesn't take it it
doesn't take it okay yeah but this looks
looks like a comfortable position so I'm
let's play 45 straight forward in the
center probably not the best but it has
the biggest chance to score quick win I
don't want him to play Quincy five
exchanging young but essence isn't this
somewhat strange here his piece
configuration this looks weird
and now I've got an obscene one
controlling the CFR rook c 1 c 6 cm this
is so this is tricky for black it's got
a hard time to organize this night yeah
yeah this is really am oops i take it
really a bad piece i'll try to play
Bishop to d3 energy form oh no this is
checkmate wait yep checkmate is better
all right so it's 13 minutes left and
I'm in the lead yeah so now Kings Indian
a check setup simply not not much going
on ok I won't blunder this this Bishop
tried an orthotic cannot take because
this is this is the exchange
not sure if this is really yeah doesn't
doesn't really give much benefit okay
now back on the upon this is weird we
had week and week after all it's also
weird but it's mostly week the only
thing that is doing is playing quickly
yeah or g7 better better protect you
seven yeah quindi once my dear now
simplifying matters okay i'll now let's
uh let's take take this into account now
i don't want to give him any squares
it's not really weak King position ok
let's try and wait with the king it's
not like you've got many moves gap under
this piece there's no way to go okay 45
points ahead that's not too bad
okay some sort of modern one of defense
which I'm not really a huge expert off
still it looks like Holly normal
position okay black black is certainly
all right and Mary can play you five now
yeah look Sam looks very good for black
now yeah he certainly has some quite
comfortable position now oh really now
topless would be would be good now where
the secret yeah okay but this is this is
not what he intended to do getting onto
this pin f7a saying it's probably not at
the end of the world think you can just
take only 3 M really can just take maybe
I should just recapture the screen text
doesn't really bring much king king 2 h8
and he's got Brooke aveda and stuff this
kind of position has some may be much
more unpleasant as he's tied to have
seven now in this end game
it's got problems too yeah yeah but I
can I can just play a quite move and ask
him how do you protect this now now it
doesn't maybe not a bad idea i can i can
add more smooth to to strengthen the
position yeah okay yeah probably won't
get to get involved in this probably now
i'm coming with be form and i get them
get some some passer here cost you six
also gone oh yeah this is winning now
with the 22 s pawns should be winning
yeah it's no way to stop the porn
running to a 7 yeah okay this was for
smiles and only six minutes left so it
should be enough really what are three
yeah okay this is a piece
so I'm p sub of course till the game
continues I didn't really get any quick
resigner so I mean this is a smart a
look not helpful but ok then position is
I mean the position in the tournament is
rather comfortable now so I'm doesn't
really matter too much ok this wasn't a
great idea let's ups let's harass him on
the kingside h4 threatening to win yeah
peace probably 92 not before probably
wants a piece of you doesn't react now
ok now take it alright so 60 points
almost and five minutes this would be a
really really strange bit if this
wouldn't wouldn't be enough yeah
probably something like this I take with
the bishop this is strange
Wow is this this is weird looks like a
really strange move why not to d8 okay
yeah but this this should win the rope
here okay and God Bishop c4 coming this
should guarantee that i get my bishop
out out of this okay so still 60 points
and now three minutes to go i think i
have it in the bag with only this one we
had lost where castled long in this
Queens gambit stuff yeah this guy is not
moving great but it's probably a it's
probably not important and I'm through
no 80 points or seventy seventy nine
points ahead
come on let's give give me one more game
okay one you fall let's try some gamma
beta is not accepting giving me a big
center instead yeah this should be a bit
better for white with the good good
development now the week pawn on d6 yeah
b6 also really weak let's try to attack
this don't know really how I defense
nitrogen seven I can play 95 yep it is
i'm not saying i think taking is better
really with this porno down also control
the see file in the bishop on h5 is
offside just bad piece yeah probably a
45 it once he and yeah this is so which
it straps the rook 11 g7 doesn't have
any square just the age where I can
capture it
yeah okay he doesn't threaten to remove
it okay now now let's take it taking d5
next move yeah okay yeah this was this
was nice only 11 silly loss and the
other games were quite okay I think it's
just have a quick look at the final
standing here from about 60 points at
the end and quite a quite a nice journey
I think yeah I hope you enjoyed this I'm
having played dumb some of these for a
while so yeah hope you liked it and yeah
I'll be back soon with new videos